good morning John most people have a
bucket list no list of things the day
would like to do before the night hi I
have two bucket lists I have one for
myself and one for my species it's nice
to think about the things that you want
to do with your own life before you kick
the game like I want to go to the Grand
Canyon I want to soak my button the
geothermal hot spring in Iceland I won
Natalie Portman and Emma Stone to
simultaneously kiss me on the cheek
thinking about my own little goals from
my own little self is certainly
satisfying personally but I feel like
it's a little bit missing the big
picture September of 2011 NASA announced
the new Space Launch System a safer more
flexible more capable next step in
humanity's greatest journey men and
women sitting on top of the SLS won't be
traveling the same humdrum journeys to
and from the space station instead they
will once again be pushing the
boundaries of what humanity can
accomplish together
the SLS which it is important to note
will someday be named something cooler
than that is the most powerful rocket
ship ever designed let alone built fully
equipped the SLS is taller than the
Statue of Liberty can fit nine school
buses inside and has 286 thousand pounds
of cargo lift capacity that is more than
23,000 puppy-sized elephants now it's
important to note that the SLS is not in
fact spaceship the SLS is the thing that
gets the spaceship to space the
spaceship is the brand-new 20,000 pound
four seater Orion multi-purpose crew
vehicle which you may have noticed does
not have wings actually the Orion can't
have wings coming in from deep space it
will be moving 9,000 miles per hour
faster than the space shuttle ever
danced that would literally tear the
space shuttle to piece so with four
times the mass and more than two times
the interior volume of the Apollo
capsule this is not your daddy spaceship
it's been 40 years since we've had a
spacecraft capable of taking humans
beyond near Earth orbit and now we're
finally going to have that spacecraft
again yes it looks like I may actually
get the cross off some of the visitation
locations from my bucket list for
Humanity including the moon we know a
lot about the moon because we've been
there before and we've brought back
samples and walked around on the surface
and even played a little golf
number of mysteries that the moon
contains his only increased since Apollo
discovered that the moon is seismically
active we're almost certain that there
are stores of frozen water lack of an
atmosphere on the moon has preserved
pretty much everything that's ever
happened there are secrets that all of
those meteorites strewn across the
surface of the Moon can hold I want it
asteroids between Mars and Jupiter
there's a vast belt of objects that we
call the asteroid belt but also hanging
out in the asteroid belt is Ceres a
dwarf planet that is 600 miles wide and
spherical in shape possibly even
containing a subterranean ocean of
liquid water they're unmanned probes now
patrolling around the asteroid belt and
one of them will be getting to Ceres in
2015 but we're never really gonna know
as much as we could know unless we got
people on that rock our juiciest
scientific fruit in the solar system 1/3
the size of Earth atmosphere at 24
points something our long-day mount
there is to learn about our planet about
our solar system about the history of
life in the universe
it took astronauts about three days to
get to the moon to get to Mars is like
seven months these missions are
difficult they're dangerous they're
expensive we proceed into our solar
system with caution before the
announcement of the SLS and the Orion I
was beginning to think that I would
never see the day when humanity would
set foot on another planet ready to find
the answers to the questions that we
already have and even more exciting
discover all those new questions I'm no
longer worried about that if I can live
you know sort of a manageable amount of
time for a guy my age it should one day
see it and maybe that person taking that
first step it could be some young nerd
watching this video right now and if
you're out there remember me and wave hi
and I'll be sitting at home really happy
cuz I got to cross off another thing on
our bucket list John I'll see you on
Tuesday